dans l'épisode précédent des scènes
d'action et effet être décalées ou
improbables ont eu lieu
une intrigue est vraisemblable a été
installé j'aime bien les artichauts l'un
des répliques d'autres films ont été
piqués qu'on voyait trop chelou nouveau
videur est maintenant comme dans toutes
les séries après un gros cliffhanger
voici un épisode filler
c'est quoi un fils heures c'est quand tu
fais un gros cliffhanger mais que t'as
pas prévu la suite
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
salut tout le monde quand je parle de
jeu vous en doutez je parle toujours
quasiment de jeu officielle a par
exemple quand je parle de jeunesse je
parle toujours des jeux qui ressemblait
à ses bonnes vieilles cartouches grise
là avec le petit logo du sud nintendo
seal of quality qui signifie que ce jeu
était un jeu officielle autorisée par
nintendo
en fait ce système il existait surtout
pour éviter les dérives
elle avait pu voir sur atari par exemple
où tout le monde pouvait sortir son
propre jeu un peu n'importe comment ce
qui fait qu'on avait surtout des jeux
qui étaient complètement pourris ont
complètement bizarre un peu comme les
jeux porno qui était sorti sur atari
2600 j'ai hâte de voir le remake sur
kinect
du coup en fait la nes contenait une
puce qui empêchait de lire les jeux qui
n'obtenait pas le sceau officiel
nintendo
voilà donc ça c'est la version
officielle à la vraie version c'est que
c'était surtout une histoire de pognon
parce que pour avoir la liste ans
seal of quality les éditeurs étaient
obligés de verser un gros pack et rica
nintendo mais pourtant il ya quand même
bien eu des jeux non licenciés qui ont
pu fonctionner sur la nes et en général
on les reconnaît parce que comme pour
les crapauds dangereux ils ont tous une
espèce de couleurs flashy dégueulasse
d'ailleurs quand on voit le nom des
éditeurs c'est un peu les mêmes noms qui
reviennent tout le temps american vidéo
aux coloris bleu le rêve en couleurs et
ses parts ça qu'on va commencer
saillantes a sorti en 1990 younès alors
l'histoire est au dos de la boîte vous
l'a traduit donc un sinistre pouvoir
extraterrestres a pris le contrôle des
forces militaires de la terre choisi par
le destin vous êtes la seule personne
que le créatures du demo interstellaire
alors je précise parce que pour les
jeunes maintenant tous les jeux de
l'époque de la nes ont l'air super moche
mais même à l'époque de la nes avec des
jeux qui peuvent déjà beau et des jeux
qui étaient les et celui là en
l'occurrence c'est un jeu qui est très
laid c'est très laid mais en même temps
il ya tellement d'incohérences dans ce
jeu que finalement les graphismes au
bout de mon fils fait plus gaffe tu
passes ton temps à te demander pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi les arbres
flotte pourquoi ces arbres là ils vont
bien mais cela flotte dans un espèce de
de vide spatial magique ça n'a aucun
sens pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des casque
rose qui me tire dessus à ce que est ce
que c'est des extraterrestres dont parle
la boîte la terrible race extraterrestre
démoniaque des méduses
ça ne devrait pas plutôt ressembler aux
avions qu'on voit sur la boîte par
exemple chez ba ou pourquoi est-ce que
je passe à travers tous ces trucs
rose fluo c'est des gros carrés posé sur
fond noir sur mon chemin je suis pas
complètement cons ces fonds 7 des
plateformes
pourquoi est-ce que je passe à travers
sérieusement quel est l'intérêt de poser
un truc énorme qui se démarque
totalement du fond du décor si c'est pas
pour être une plateforme et ce machin là
qui ressemble à une grosse miche de pain
pourquoi en fait c'est d'une mine c'est
une demande en la personne la plus conne
du monde de dessiner une mine vue de
profil il va faire un truc qui ressemble
à ça bon ok peut-être pas la plus connue
du monde mais il va faire un truc qui
ressemble à celle par le feu il va pas
décider un truc en forme de haricot quoi
je reçois les camions ressemble à ça le
principe du camouflage d'un camion
militaire c'est d'être discret alors à
moins que le jeu éventuellement se passe
dans tard le city et pour l'amour de
dieu mais pourquoi est ce que les
ennemis quand tu n'es tu se transforme
en chauve-souris
pourquoi est-ce que ça a un rapport avec
l'histoire
les extraterrestres méduses démoniaque
qui soit arrivée sur terre pour faire
voler les sapins mais ce le super soldat
pour aller vaincre en transformant
l'humanité en chant story je crois que
c'est quand même un exploit de réussir à
faire un truc qui n'a aucune logique du
début à la fin je dire même dans un jeu
de merde normalement mais même
volontairement tu vas faire un truc même
sans faire exprès un truc un minimum
sens et je veux dire le cerveau humain
est conditionnée quand même pour
produire des choses logique des choses
sensées mais là c'est comme si c'était
cohérent mais dans le what the fuck ya
forcément un mec qui a supervisé moment
pour que ce soit aussi régulièrement
merdique du début à la fin quoi monsieur
le maire regardez cet écran on dirait le
jeu des sept erreurs alors là au dessus
on voit d'une muraille
ce n'est pas une plateforme c'est juste
une muraille volante décoratives qui ne
sert à rien on ne peut pas y accéder
vous voyez je passe à travers donc avec
au dessus un camion qui volent et des
arbres qui vole donc sa mutuelle tout va
bien en bas il ya des tonneaux collé au
plafond comme si un mec avait raté une
partie de tetris ou via des cercueils ou
je sais pas trop avec une croix regarde
s'il ya deux cercueils posait sur un
échafaudage volant et à côté il ya une
bible posé sur un présentoir
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce jeu
sérieusement et c'est pareil pour le
décor y ait jamais moyen de servante qui
fait partie du décor ou pas le genre
vous voyez par exemple ce mirador je
passe à travers quinze mètres plus loin
le même mirador exactement le même pas
un pixel différence c'était du fond
d'écran maintenance est une plateforme
super et ça l'a tué
arrêtez moi si c'est un escalier ça la
forme d'un escalier c'est pourquoi je ne
sais je je passe à travers ça ne sert à
rien expliquez-moi pourquoi tu mets un
truc en forme d'escalier si ce n'est pas
pour servir d'escalier j'ai l'impression
de devenir fou ce jeu je te jure
bon ensuite niveau musique c'est génial
on dirait les musiques qui passent sur
les petites voitures à l'entrée des
supermarchés
ensuite niveau 2 tu fais trois mètres à
longvic quand tu tues des ennemis images
des items qui tombe dans le sol
automatiquement quatre mètres plus bas
ces pratiques un espace surtout quand
les concepteurs de cette purge ont pensé
à mettre des échelles pour aller en bas
mais par contre ils ont oublié de mettre
les trous pour accéder aux échelles a b
c chouette comme ça au moins ça me
laisse le temps d'admirer les décors
d'admirer la diversité des couleurs
incroyables de ce niveau au regard des
sérieux les murs en rose les camions
sont roses les ennemis sont roses à un
moment tu montes à une échelle dans le
niveau 2 c'est quoi ça ils ont oublié de
mettre un décor là où est ce que j'ai
acheté la version katy perry du jeu
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des trous dans
les textures de cet avion pourquoi
est-ce qui un tank qui fait la hauteur
de mes genoux ces mignons peut-être que
je sais pas c'est le cadeau bonus du
menu enfant du burger king qui a juste à
côté
tous les niveaux sont comme ça le niveau
4 c'est un désert avec un temple chinois
à la fin tu affrontes un gradient le nid
5 c'est un complexe ultra futuriste à la
fête qui affronte un ordinateur qui fait
le niveau 6 est une fête foraine une
fête foraine
comment on est passé dans le scénario de
trucs futuriste dans une usine où une
base ou un truc où je suis dans une fête
foraine où je tue des mecs déguisés en
pinocchio au milieu d'eux de girafe
bleue avec un escalier dans le cul tu
crois que c'est marqué ça sur la boîte
bien sûr que non comment t'as fait ça
c'est ma vidéo je fais ce que je veux
le niveau 7 donc c'est une forêt qui
excuse en plus je m'en fous à level
niveau 7 donc c'est une forêt wind est
d'ailleurs noter que pour les boss vous
ne savez jamais à quel endroit vous
devez taper pour les blessés par exemple
sur l'arbre ça va être le nez une fois
ça va être les yeux sur l'ordinateur ça
être lent trop le nez et les yeux fabre
f
et donc on arrive au dernier boss de
sphinx qui crachent des bulles pas moins
logique que ce qu'ils avaient avant et
donc quand vous avez tué ce boss vous
avez droit à la fin du jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une
lui
[Musique]
e
réd 2020 sortie en 89 aux états unis et
c'est troublant quand même à 2020 donc
sorti en 89 uniquement aux états unis et
en australie
je pourrais citer les enfants ne pas
preuve de drogue vous le voyez en haut à
gauche
winner fights drugs les gagnants
combattre la drogue
sauf lui donc l'histoire en 2020 un
fléau de narcotiques se répand sur
l'économique
ok d'accord merci quand même donc le jeu
commence sur le port et on voit
simplement avancé devant soi en tuant
tout ce qui passait en ramassant les
items par exemple tout de suite au début
du jeu vous pouvez dans le premier
bâtiment ramasser une meilleure arme et
là vous vous dites mais comment faire
l'armée trop haute je saute pas assez
haut il n'y a pas de plateforme pour y
accéder et la solution est ce que c'est
vraiment moche
pareil à l'extérieur si vous voulez les
bottes il faut sauter sur la mouche et
là vous constaterez en appuyant sur
select que rien n'a changé vous n'allez
pas plus vite ce qui c'est logique vous
ne tirez pas plus fort vous n'avez pas
gagné de points
conclusion exactement cet item est il
bon le gameplay de ce jeu est assez
basique finalement la seule difficulté
ça vient surtout du fait qu'on ne peut
pas aller d'autant bas puisque votre
personnage en fait se déplace selon des
lignes obliques parallèle donc ce qui
rend en fait de la navigation un peu
difficile surtout quand il faut slalomer
au milieu des tomates écrasées
parce que oui en 2020 les tomates
écrasées vous tue d'autant que pour
faciliter le boulot vous devez vous
concentrer sur les tomates tout en
essayant d'éviter les mouettes qui vous
chie dessus et qui en 2020 bosse pour le
cartel de la drogue
le but du jeu comme je les dis ça n'est
absolument pas de récupérer la drogue
qui traînent partout dans les niveaux et
ça c'est pas le boulot d'un agent des
stups
faut pas déconner mais bel et bien de
faire tomber impitoyablement le glaive
de la justice en butant froidement tous
les dealers et ça qu'ils ressemblent à
des portugais à de vieux
exhibitionnistes ou voie d
thorn trompeur bref nous voilà au niveau
2 et là un nouveau concept de dimension
s'offre à nous je m'explique
le niveau est en vue de trois quarts les
ennemis gens les hélicos sont en vue de
dessus et mon personnage est en vue de
côté
donc on affronte des hélicoptères qui
font 30 cm de diamètre des ours et qui
tire des lasers des requins qui
ressemble au chien de mario des trucs
qui ressemble au paramécies que je
faisais dans sport tout ça avec mon
scooter rose fuchsia modèle barbie va à
la plage
mais rassurez vous je parle des décors
et des ennemis mais le gameplay aussi
est à chier évidemment puisque ce jeu et
durera en creux d un camp c'est pas les
sources est immortel qui vous tue c'est
un hélicoptère qui vous transperce
littéralement de part en part et quand
vous recommencez le niveau donnez-moi de
seconde en fait tu commençais le niveau
j'ai déjà perdu les deux tiers de ma
part de vive et laissez moi devrons
tranquille
bon alors pour vous aider dans la
plupart des niveaux vous pourrez
utiliser des véhicules mais là encore il
faut faire gaffe parce que souvent dans
les niveaux il ya plusieurs bâtiments
qui te change les véhicules dans
certains niveaux et donc du coup ça
arrive souvent de changer un bon
véhicule contre truc complètement à
chier j'adore comment le mec qui rentre
dans nos magasins avec son vaisseau
spatial je trouve ça super classe
bonjour monsieur qu'est ce que je peux
faire pour vous tiens regarde j'ai un
super vaisseau qui volent et qui tue
tout le monde super facilement et si je
rentrais dans ce bâtiment pour
l'échanger contre une moto pourri qui
vole pas et qui explose tout seul s'est
passé sur quoi je suis mort bon écoute
et on va faire simple ce jeu c'est de la
merde y'a rien à garder rien niveau
gameplay c'est pourri niveau histoire
rien n'a pas niveau difficulté il ya des
passages qui sont imposables
le pire du pire pour moi et pire point
du jeu niveau sonore
c'est du dépucelage auditifs très
sérieusement et je dis pas ça parce que
vos oreilles saignent à la fin c'est
insoutenable
il n'y a pas d'autres mots on dirait des
bruitages d'atari 2600 c'est typiquement
le genre de jeu de le genre de son au
bout de cinq minutes il ya ta mère ou
ton père qui rentrait dans la pièce et
qui te disais bonjour mon petit tu
t'amuses bien mais se consolent la tue
pas une seconde
bref niveau iv maintenant tu te bats
contre des robots géants avec une tête
de chien des daft punk des power rangers
noire des trucs qui tient des éclairs
des flaques verte pas in her des rats
géants très méchant des après ski très
jolie des araignées très agité des
grottes fourmi est riche de sucre
c'est n'importe quoi [ __ ] mais si je
l'étais pour lutter contre la drogue
la première chose à faire s'arrêter que
le développeur ne prennent pas le niveau
4 on n'entend plus rien à [ __ ] de la
drogue battus à tous les niveaux
précédents consistait à tuer les dealers
là maintenant on s'en branle n'a pu rien
à [ __ ] maintenant on va dans les
sous-sols et puis il faut comprendre que
cette excroissance de terre miniature
est en fait un ascenseur ben oui parce
que nous chez cooler dreams on n'aime
pas les portes
alors on met 3 pixels en forme de bits
par terre tu vois on appelle ça un
ascenseur et puis on en met plein
regarde pas ce qu'on te dit que le jeu
il était tellement bon qu'il fallait
faire durer le plaisir
1 et puis après on fait pareil avec les
portes si elle gère par exemple tu
passes une porte ça t'amène à un endroit
tu reprends la même porte une seconde
après et ça te ramène au début du niveau
oui parce qu'en fait le début dit niveau
c'est la porte des marques est sorti
quoi t'es pas content et puis après on
part toujours des gens régner dans une
salle où y'a plein pot d'araignée et
puis on se sert des chauves souris comme
tremplin parce que la chauve souris
c'est le transport de demain
voilà allez laisse moi monté fusain et
non pas par là de merde
oh là là mais je regarde je peux faire
pourrir dans un bois là mais pas de ce
côté pauv'con
bon bref on n'a pas que ça à faire et
maintenant il faut aller ramasser qu'une
clé dont le ventre d'une fourmi voilà et
mais attention parce que les fourmis
elles sont trop basses et tu peux pas
tirer dessus directement un parce que tu
peux pas de bettié et ben oui alors à
chaque fois que tu vois une fourmi mais
il faut te démerder pour aller rendre en
contrebas pour l'heure six rebonds pour
leur tirer dessus en sautant en l'air
voilà c'était vachement plus simple de
faire ça plutôt d'ajouter une touche
pour se baisser
1 et puis après la fourmi est lâche une
bonne grosse clé bien moyenâgeuse m
koné un futur et puis après on va
affronter le boss final le boss final
c'est un orc qui font du skate
1 et puis après il ya l'écran de fin qui
nous dit que les les gagnants ils ont
pas besoin de drogue
pour le gagnant je t'avoue que je ne
sais pas mais moi là tout de suite j'en
ai vraiment besoin ya qu une seule
manière de finir cette vidéo pour le jeu
comme ça
[Musique]
ce
tan tan tan tan tan tan dung datant
d'avant de la table